un testículo no descendido es una
afección en la que una o ambas glándulas
reproductoras masculinas no han bajado
desde el vientre o el abdomen del bebé
hacia el escroto
normalmente antes del nacimiento los
testículos del bebé crecen dentro del
abdomen los testículos junto con sus
vasos sanguíneos se desplazan hacia
abajo a través de estructuras en forma
de tubo llamados conductos inguinal es
hasta el escroto
a veces por razones desconocidas uno o
ambos testículos no bajan hacia el
escroto antes del nacimiento
un testículo no descendido puede
permanecer en el abdomen
en los conductos seminales
o justo por encima del escroto
también puede emigrar a la base del pene
u otras zonas
la mitad de las veces los testículos
descienden al escroto en los 90 días
posteriores al nacimiento
pero si no descienden esta persona puede
tener problemas para procrear cuando sea
adulto también puede aumentar el riesgo
de presentar cáncer testicular
los testículos no descendidos a menudo
requieren una operación llamada arqueo
pecs ya el procedimiento se recomienda
durante el primer año después del
nacimiento si el testículo del bebé está
dentro debajo del conducto inguinal se
puede realizar una cirugía abierta para
comenzar el cirujano hará una pequeña
incisión en la ingle
el testículo se liberará de algunos de
los tejidos circundantes
el cirujano hará una segunda incisión en
el escroto
el testículo junto con sus vasos
sanguíneos se hará bajar al escroto
donde unos puntos de sutura lo
mantendrán en su lugar por último las
incisiones se cerrarán con puntos de
sutura
si el testículo se encuentra en el
abdomen se puede realizar una horca o
pex ya laparoscópica para comenzar el
cirujano hará dos o tres pequeñas
incisiones en el abdomen del bebé
a través de estas incisiones se
insertarán unos pequeños tubos para una
cámara e instrumentos quirúrgicos
el cirujano utilizará los instrumentos
para liberar el testículo de parte del
tejido circundante
luego se hará otra incisión en la parte
inferior del escroto
el cirujano insertará un instrumento en
esta incisión para alcanzar el testículo
y tirar de este hacia abajo en el
escroto
unos puntos de sutura mantendrán el
testículo en su posición dentro del
escroto
por último las incisiones se cerrarán
con pegamento cutáneo o cinta adhesiva
a veces los vasos sanguíneos que van a
un testículo no descendido no son lo
suficientemente largos para permitir que
el testículo baje al escroto
en este caso el bebé puede necesitar dos
procedimientos quirúrgicos durante el
primer procedimiento se atarán algunos
de los vasos sanguíneos más cortos con
el paso del tiempo otros vasos
sanguíneos se encargarán de suministrar
sangre al testículo
y luego en el segundo procedimiento el
cirujano dividirá los vasos sanguíneos
más cortos que ya no son necesarios y se
bajará el testículo hasta el escroto
unos puntos de sutura mantendrán el
testículo en su posición dentro del
escroto
para obtener más información sobre los
procedimientos de orck'o pecs ya hablé
con su médico